so today we're going to talk about
arrhythmias and how they relate to
excessive amounts of calcium stuck
inside your cell now arrhythmias relate
to a problem with the rhythm of your
heart it could be a minor palpitation it
could be a major atrial fibrillation
but anything that is abnormal from the
regular rhythm of the heartbeat
it's called arrhythmias now I will say
there's other reasons for arrhythmias
like hyperthyroidism that could be one
but when I'm done with this presentation
all roads lead to excessive calcium
inside your cells this is why one of the
medications they may use for rithmatist
will be a calcium channel blocker now
calcium is just one of the electrolytes
that you have in your body
electrolytes are those electrically
charged minerals that help conduct
electricity through the body through the
nervous system and that can activate
muscles so you have sodium as an
electrolyte and that can act as the
spark and calcium has to do with the
squeeze or contraction of the heart and
then the relaxation phase is controlled
by magnesium now there's many triggers
to palpitations heart arrhythmias which
by the way many times occur more at
night during the day but you have
caffeine for example that would be
obviously during the day
now why would caffeine trigger an
arrhythmia or a palpitation simply
because it alters calcium physiology
same thing with alcohol it alters
calcium in the body sugar will do it
stress will do it as in cortisol certain
electrolytes affect calcium low vitamin
D can affect calcium for sure and
there's certain chemicals in chocolate
that can alter the calcium and this is
why a lot of people notice that after
consuming chocolate or even caffeine or
alcohol or sugar or going through stress
they feel like a little palpitation in
the heart or the heart skips a beat
things like that and then there are
certain drugs that alter calcium to
specifically are the antipsychotic drugs
and the antidepressant drugs both drive
calcium inside the cell and increase the
risk for a rhythm
which could actually lead to sudden
death so you can look at these as
triggers so now the question is how do
we make sure we don't have excessive
amounts of calcium inside your cells
well one of the biggest controllers are
preventing calcium inside the cell would
be this man right here at magnesium
magnesium is one of the primary
controllers of calcium and preventing
too much from getting inside the cell
magnesium is also involved in keeping
your potassium high outside the cell
when normally it's supposed to be inside
the cell and also magnesium is supposed
to be inside the cell like 99% of it
you're supposed to be inside that only
1% should be outside and this leads to
another problem of testing when you
check your blood for magnesium levels
you're really only testing 1% of all of
the body's magnesium and this is the
worst place to test magnesium you really
want to do an intracellular test I will
put a link down below of a good lab I
had mine done recently and it did come
out normal there's also a tremendous
amount of people that have a magnesium
deficiency
it's subclinical so they may not have a
lot of symptoms they may have one or two
magnesium is also involved in keeping
sodium low inside the cell as well as
calcium so it wants to keep calcium and
magnesium out of this cell and potassium
inside the cell any type of imbalance
with these electrolytes throws off the
entire electrical system of the body and
this is where you get like a short
circuiting in effect which basically
describes an arrhythmia couple reasons
why you might be magnesium deficient it
could be that you're consuming too many
refined carbs or sugar or have insulin
resistance or you're pre-diabetic or
you're diabetic all of those will keep
magnesium allow could be that you're not
consuming enough magnesium from your
diet because you don't like vegetables
by the way most of the magnesium in the
food supply is in the leafy greens
because green is part of the chlorophyll
complex and magnesium is at the center
of it there's also a very important pump
that allows these mineral exchanges to
happen
and each one of your cells has billions
of these sodium potassium pumps and
these are very important in allowing
magnesium other electrolytes to be
traveled through this exchange mechanism
and then to reverse that if you don't
have enough magnesium potassium and
sodium won't work as well so as you can
see it gets really complex but don't
worry it's going to get more complex
because there's a vitamin k2 which also
has an effect on calcium vitamin k2
helps to take the calcium which is in
the wrong place in your body the soft
tissues like in the heart on the nerves
in the joints and the kidney and push
that in back into the bone so having
enough k2 can also protect excessive
calcium with inside the cell also
vitamin d3 helps to alter calcium and
reduce the risk of arrhythmias but what
I wanted to tell you in this video is
that there's a core problem with
arrhythmias and it has to do with excess
of calcium in the wrong place and
there's many different triggers that can
cause this so what you probably should
do to figure this out is to scan through
the various things that I said and see
if you're doing too much caffeine too
much alcohol
too much sugar have too much stress or
maybe you're not getting enough
magnesium which is probably one of the
biggest factors or let's see you're low
in vitamin D or you're eating too much
chocolate are you taking drugs that have
side effects that's what you need to do
is look through those and see if you can
correct that to put your heart back in
rhythm and the other thing I would
recommend is instead of trying to take
one mineral to try to correct it consume
food that has all the minerals in the
right proportions that would be the
ideal scene but you would need to
consume about seven to ten cups of
vegetables per day to start to build up
those minerals now you can also do
electrolyte powder that has all of them
in there and realize that it does take
some time it could take three to four
possibly five months to remineralize
your body if you're very deficient don't
get about vitamin k2 and d3 as well
thanks for watching and I have another
video in electrolytes that you may be
interested I put it right here